merci d'accueillir maintenant jérôme
chamba bonjour à tous pas de souci c'est
pas branché merci pour le jeune aussi
cyril 4 milliard sais pas si vous le
savez mais sur la planète il ya quatre
milliards d'êtres humains qui vivent
dans les villes
et ça c'est juste aujourd'hui 2 % du
territoire
4 milliards de personnes alors selon les
prévisions on prévoit qu'en 2050
ce sera 6 milliard de personnes qui
vivront dans les villes pour 3 dans les
zones rurales
donc aujourd'hui on parle d'un autre
demain et l'autre demain pour deux tiers
de l'humanité
il va se passer dans un seul endroit
dans la cité dans la vide et ça y est
les défis colossaux qui s'annonce en
fait parce que la densité de population
dans un très petit espace
on connaît tous ce que ça produit ça
produit des problèmes de transport ça
produit de problèmes de pollution de
sécurité d'énergie tout un tas de
problèmes qui vont s'amplifier dans les
années à venir
c'est juste le début en fait et pour
répondre à ça quelques années les
américains qui sont les champions du
monde du marketing
on peut aussi une super idée qui
s'appelle smart city la ville
intelligente avec un cerveau tu es ce
concept il a été poussé essentiellement
par cisco et par ibm avec une idée assez
simple finalement c'est que
l'informatique de manière générale la
date à tout ça a beaucoup de formidables
aller tout résoudre
magique on va connecter n'importe quoi
dans tous les sens on va les croisés on
a trouvé des solutions à tous bon c'est
pas nouveau que les géants de latex
s'intéresse à la ville c'est un super
terrain de jeu vous avez tous google
maps pas tous au moins 80% d'entre vous
google maps aujourd'hui vous permet dans
la ville de mieux vous orienter d'éviter
les bouchons
airbnb a profondément changé la façon
dont elle est le logement sont occupés
en ville et puis qu'est-ce qui est en
train d'arriver maintenant je sais pas
si vous le savez mais google va
construire sa ville ça y est la google
dix qui sont associés avec toronto et
c'est une ville vous savez moi j'ai un
enfant qui joue beaucoup à accepter
mobile ils vont pouvoir tout faire
depuis d'un partant de zéro avec des
jolies rues bien large où on pourra
faire passer des bus électriques qui
fonctionneront tous seuls les déchets
vont se connecter tout seul ça va être
formidable tout le monde sera super
heureux il faut pas en douter
c'est google qui le dit la whey parce
que moi cette smart cities ta vous voyez
j'ai un petit problème avec est en fait
elles problème que j'ai c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on ramène tout ça de la
technologie et finalement c'est pour le
bénéfice de l'utilisateur de ces
entreprises
avec quoi google 2 gagnent de l'argent
quoi son business model
la pub pour raconter tout ce que vous
voulez web à ces dons c'est la pub
donc moi personnellement j'ai pas
particulièrement envie ma ville devienne
un gigantesque panneau publicitaire
j'ai envie d'autre chose et la
problématique c'est comment la ville la
cité peut reprendre la main face on peut
faire en tout cas contrepoids face aux
géants de la tech pas facile pour la
ville très compliqué hein pourquoi parce
que d'une part elle n'a pas la force de
frappe de ses grands groupes qui vont
des de collecte des données depuis des
données depuis des années sur les usages
des utilisateurs et elle n'a pas non
plus forcément toutes les compétences
pour le faire elle n'a pas la puissance
financière
comment on peut faire comment on peut
faire pour remettre le citoyen nous quoi
nous qui vivons dans ces villes au
centre de ce système là elle a quand
même des atouts la ville mais elle ne
sait pas toujours où en tout cas je
pense qu'elle n'exploite pas assez
elle a deux atouts le premier atout il
est contestable contester on peut en
discuter c'est la réglementation
vous le savez il ya des villes weeber
est quasi interdite c'est une solution 1
ça nous pose un problème on l'arrête on
interdit réglementation
airbnb c'est pareil a pas de raison non
plus qui reviennent vite perdre payent
pas de taxe par rapport aux hôteliers
très bien on les taxe va bien on
réglemente mais il ya un deuxième atout
qui est vraiment centrale 7 territoires
c'est le
que la ville elle a encore quelque chose
que pour l'instant les géants du
numérique n'ont pas territoire pourquoi
c'est important on fait le territoire et
pourquoi ça peut changer la donne
comme on fait google maps à votre avis
pour savoir si un bouchon un feu rouge à
chambéry caméra quelque part non il
collecte en temps réel des milliers
d'interactions les vôtres c'est pas
parce que vous avez pas google maps
d'ailleurs que vous n'êtes pas concerné
et regarde combien de personnes qui sont
passées à cet endroit là à ce point gps
en même temps et à quelle vitesse ils
sont baladés et à partir de ça ils vont
vous dire en temps réel si un bouchon
ici comment vous pouvez le contourner et
c'est ça marche comme ça mais vous savez
quoi avec le territoire avec un capteur
au bon endroit
vous pouvez faire exactement la même
chose ouais compter les voitures aux
feux
vous comprendrez l'info en temps réel
vous avez le même résultat au final
devait pas besoin de devoir tout ces
data sauf que jusqu'ici
s'il avait fallu instrumenté toutes les
villes avec des capteurs à chaque feu à
chaque endroit à chaque place de parking
dans chaque collector de 17 des déchets
sarr a coûté une fortune
il aurait fallu le connecter déjà
alimentés électriquement faire des
travaux le faire que communiquer avec
des descentes et détroit de la 3g la 4g
alors le wifi j'en parle même pas et ces
dernières années les nouvelles
technologies qui a émergé et qui a rendu
de nouvelles choses possibles et je vais
essayer de vous la faire aimer
non je suis pas sûr d'y arriver pour
changer aussi en tout cas vous
l'expliquer et vous expliquer pourquoi
elle est en train aussi de pas mal
changé de choses dans les villes
actuellement un peu plus de technologie
comme toutes les technologies elle a un
nom super barbare c'est les lp one qui
avait déjà entendu parler d'elle
plouasne vous me rassurer non parce que
jamais et el pais one c'est quoi
concrètement c'est une technologie
télécommunications qui permet de faire
communiquer des objets de cette taille
là pendant dix ans sur piles en temps
réel
passant de le connecter de le brancher
ce que voulaient par des capteurs de
température des capteurs de parking tout
ce que vous voulez donc vous pouvez
instrumenté la ville mettre des capteurs
partout et récupérer la donner et c est
ces réseaux en fait ils sont aujourd'hui
présents dans cette salle vous savez pas
ce que votre smartphone ne le voit pas
mais ils sont là il y en a il y en a
trois ici dans cette salle
pour ceux qui auraient mal à la tête au
cas où
donc ça émet 80 fois moins que le
moindre gsm sur la m bandes de
fréquences si j'avais vraiment un
problème avec les ondes
coupez votre téléphone fat rassurez vous
ça vous fera pas beaucoup de mal et ses
réseaux en fait ils sont opérés par des
gens que vous connaissez
orange a un réseau un réseau ici qui
permet à ces objets de communiquer
bouygues telecom a une filiale qui a un
réseau qui permet de communiquer est
vrai aussi les nouveaux entrants comme
si knox sur des technologies qui
permettent de le faire
là où ça devient intéressant car on
parle de réseaux de télécoms comme des
poteaux trois géants vous voyez sur les
bord du chemin
là où c'est intéressant cette
technologie est un mais aussi de
déployer son propre réseau
vous allez voir pourquoi c'est
intéressant et pourquoi ça change
beaucoup de choses là qu'une antenne
comme ça en champ libre donc plutôt dans
les bauges qu'à chambéry
d'accord vous pouvez collecter les
informations issues de capteurs qui
peuvent être jusqu'à 15 kilomètres de
distance une seule antenne à peu près
450 euros qui veut dire que les villes
peuvent aujourd'hui créer des réseaux de
télécommunications basé sur cette
technologie pour au final avoir un coût
de collecte de l'information qui est
très très faible
et c'est pour ça que vous avez vu ces
dernières années fleurir énormément de
projets autour de ça alors on ne
s'appelle la y'at-il internet des objets
un langage dont profane et le cas plein
de villes c'est la courte dans tous les
sens un paris lyon bordeaux 500 capteurs
saint-sulpice-la-forêt 1400 habitants
qui a fait son projet ce parti avec
cette techno là il investit dans du
sperme enfin que des trucs part je vous
passe le smart comme ça on ira plus vite
qu'avec dans les bâtiments pour les
déchets les tas de choses ils ont
investi ils ont fait leur propre réseau
r- chambéry aussi on a fait ça on a fait
ça avec la collectivité avec des start
up du territoire avec l'association
french tech indians et on est tous
arrivés à la même conclusion ça marche
technologiquement mais est ce qu'on va
pouvoir pour autant tenir les promesses
de la smart cities et d'ailleurs c'est
quoi un l'efficacité des services
publics
2 le mieux vivre dans la ville et tout
ça bien sûr dans une optique de
développement durable
mais est ce que parce que j'ai mis une
antenne et j'ai collecté plein de choses
à droite à gauche
j'ai vraiment je me suis attaqué à ces
problèmes et pour vous montrer les défis
non technologiques que nous allons
devoir tous ensemble et collectivement
surmonter pour faire une vraie ville
intelligente vous prendre trois exemples
premier exemple sur vous en avez entendu
parler
linky c'est même pour
vous en avez entendu parler je sûr qu a
pas beaucoup de gens qui pourrait me
dire à quoi sert par contre je suis sûr
que beaucoup d'entre nous pourra nous
dire pourquoi les gens n'en veulent pas
cette sympathique petite parenthèse
rapide solide chibli promoteur ni pour
ni contre bien au contraire qu'il était
juste un peu à quoi ça sert ni dans une
optique on veut avoir tous des voitures
électriques demain on veut connecter nos
éoliennes faire des panneaux solaires
mélangez tout ça dans un grand mix et
faire en sorte ça se casse pas tout la
figure
linky c'est une brique très importante
donc le développement durable tout ça
c'est bien mais sans mesurer
correctement l'énergie est capable de
savoir ce qui se passe très compliqué
même si mme clinton qui aujourd'hui tout
le monde le connaît pour une seule
raison à ça donne mal à la tête
on a des freeplugs chez nous la télé qui
passe dans le cpl ça vous envoie des
gigas de données par seconde là pas mal
à la tête
linky mal à la tête et le deuxième
argument c'est il ya un mec sur sa
chaise qui nous surveillent à chaque
instant parce que notre vie est
tellement importante privé que les
contrôles et janry mais c'est pas
vraiment drôle en fait quand on y pense
on est certes comprendre pourquoi on en
est arrivé là sur un projet communiqué
le deuxième exemple la pollution travail
récemment avec des politiques avec qui
on discute est un peu de ça de la vie
intelligente qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire et à une idée qui a émergé ses
dires le garn une super idée
on va demander aux gens de mettre des
capteurs de pollution sur la balcon les
volontaires et puis comme ça on pourra
voir ce qui se passe et où moi je
m'attendais à ce qu'ils disaient c'était
où j'avais faire ça mais on va inquiéter
les gens disent qu'on va faire on peut
rien faire deuxième exemple
troisième exemple sur ma télécommande
alors ça c'est une des fameuses c'est le
bus recharger à l'arrêt j'explique le
principe c'est un bus électrique dans la
ville
il arrive sur une voie où il n'y a pas
de voiture il s'arrête et un bras qui
sort et met assez d'énergie pour que le
bus face deux arrêts
j'étais à paris le joueur alors je sais
plus où c'était exactement je vois un de
ces braves arrêts et les gens ont bien
respecté vous à vue ils ont bien laissé
la place pour le bus sauf qu'un camion
devant un camion derrière donc j'ai vu
le bus passe et il n'a pas pu s'arrêter
évidemment j'espère pour lui que l'arrêt
suivant il a réussi à le faire parce
qu'il allait s'arrêter de toute façon
brillant il ya des mecs intelligents qui
vont réfléchir ça technologies et
puissant le truc hein ça ça vous envoie
la purée pendant 20 secondes
vous avez de quoi faire rouler votre bus
pour 2,1 alors ces exemples peut
permettre vraiment de mettre en avant
les trois défis qui nous attendent le
premier défi il est qu'on fera rien sans
impliquer les citoyens c'est fini dean
qui c'est un projet où on a dit à tout
le monde pas à discuter les gars ça vous
coûte rien c'est comme ça c'est génial
ouvrez vos portes mettez le compteur
chez vous mais on a le droit de faire ça
on voit le résultat
un truc qui aurait pu être un projet
génial s'il avait expliqué où on a pu
faire des aménagements à la limite on en
arrive là donc un impliquer le citoyen
lorsqu'il concernant sa vie la deuxième
chose c'est que ça sert à rien de mesure
et de mettre des capteurs si derrière on
sait pas quoi faire
pas de levier d'action pas de mesure
c'est pas la peine
le coût de la pollution en effet qui
d'ailleurs n'a rien de vie de faire on
sait rien faire on n'a pas envie on sait
pas on ne fait pas enfin c'est la
deuxième chose est la troisième chose
qui est pour moi essentiel c'est ça
l'adaptation au contexte on via
chambériens ya des projets de smart
cities à dubaï
masdar city voit c'est le désert briller
on part de zéro on peut pas se tromper
quoi
chambéry a des rues pavées et des rues
étroites et des gens qui gardent
n'importe comment ou est-ce que c'est
dans ma rue c'est pareil moi pareil ça
m'arrive et des châteaux et des rues
story qui a déjà de l'un des choix ouais
donc la ville intelligente de dubaï
imaginé par les géants du numérique
appliquée à chambéry ça donne des trucs
comme ça quoi ça sert les trois premiers
défis il va falloir vraiment relevé qu'
on veut vraiment faire une ville
intelligente
je rajouterais 2 1 c'est la formation et
la prise en compte de sa part les
politiques suis pas en train de faire du
politique bashing ça m'intéresse pas du
tout par contre il ya un chose qui est
sûre c'est que si eux sont pas à la
pointe de ça si il pousse pas s'ils sont
pas en pointe là dessus on aura un
problème c'est complexe comme sujet
ça fait pas appel qu'au bon sens ça fait
aussi appel à des contraintes et tout un
tas de choses et donc s'il faut vraiment
que nos hommes politiques prennent pas
en compte et se forment là dessus pas
grave c'est pas assez pas mal de se
former ça arrive moi un truc que je
connais pas mais on va être obligé de
faire rentrer ça dans la cité la
technologie pour qu'elle soit au service
des gens il faut bien la comprendre il
faut en comprendre les limites il faut
en comprendre les implications et puis
le dernier point est aussi le nerf de la
guerre c'est le financement et ouais
notation collectivités le bes et ça
c'est très inquiétant
pourquoi parce que quand google investit
la smart cities quand ils font leurs
propres villes intelligentes ils ont un
business model en tête
eh ouais à la fin ils vont vous revendre
leurs propres données ils vont faire de
l'argent avec
ils ont surtout et c'est pas que je suis
j'ai rien contre le commerce ça c'est
formidable et pour la ville qui a pas
cette possibilité
a priori c'est que de la dépense donc
c'est quand même il ya quand même
beaucoup de défis qui n'ont rien à voir
avec la technologie
j'ai essayé de vous montrer que
technologiquement on sait faire des tas
de choses géniales ya un univers des
possibles qui est fantastique et il va
falloir réfléchir maintenant comment on
fait collectivement pour que ce soit au
service du citoyen et pas au service du
géant des géants du numérique
ces pousses
alors je vous rassure il ya l'espoir je
vais vous citer un exemple intéressant
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que on
pouvait avec ses petites antennes la
créer des réseaux dans les villes à
moindre coût en investissant il ya des
hollandais et lodève roland un petit peu
on pourrait dire qu'ils ont monté un
projet qui est fantastique et je vous
invite à aller voir comment ça marche
notés çà s'appelle ttn je suis nul en
anglais mais c'est aussi network pardon
pour l'accent qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est même pas la collectivité et à ses
antennes c'est les citoyens
il ya cinquante trois antennes juste sur
la ville d'amsterdam qui sont hébergés
chez des citoyens ce qui fait vous
mettez n'importe quel capteur dans la
ville sans aucun coût vous pouvez
communiquer et inventer de nouvelles
applications autour de ça ils ont
répondu cette idée partout dans le monde
il y en a désormais en afrique partout
en europe donc il ya des gens qui ont
réussi à inventer un nouveau modèle à la
fois dans la captation de l'information
mais aussi de se dire qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait en faire il organise des
ateliers
oui et c'est ensemble d'imaginer les
usages de demain et à chambéry dans
l'agglomération il ya plusieurs acteurs
qui ont eu une idée assez m
on va dire similaire mais qui va encore
un peu plus loin c'est un challenge qui
s'appelle akamba alors à comme passer du
patois savoyard
ça veut dire collecter recueillir il est
c'est quoi c'est d'essayer justement de
résoudre un peu cette quadrature du
cercle en impliquant tous les acteurs du
territoire car il ya un truc super oc
qui se fait dans l'agglo c'est la
fabrique du territoire ça peut être une
bonne base par exemple c'est à dire 1 on
va impliquer les citoyens leur demander
à eux
vous voulez en faire quoi de la techno
pour aller où première chose d'eux de
demander aux gens qui ont la technologie
en l'occurrence a peut être des start up
ça peut aussi être des grands groupes de
dire mais par rapport au contexte
ici vous êtes là vous n'êtes pas abouba
y vous êtes page pas ou qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
d'impliquer la collectivité pour que les
agents publics aussi montent dans le
bateau ils connaissent bien les
problématiques cd impliqué là dedans et
les bêtes tous ces acteurs autour d'une
table pour réellement faire une smart
cities qui soit pas au service
allez on va dire des géants du numérique
au service des citoyens et c'est
j'espère qu'on verra les chambériens à
ces réunions et vous participerez avec
nous à la construction de cet autre
demain merci
[Applaudissements]